Haa
[music] The
pure white snow is sucking my life away
God
bless me I feel like the line judge is on fire I want to
die so much It's
okay People don't know this much
And you're not ready to die just yet  Deaf
[music]
So
do your best
[music] In my
fading consciousness
I heard a very gentle voice
That was
my first conversation with my wife
How many farewells
have been washed away The fountain in the ward where he threw up is he Hotel
Toka I'm sure it will continue even after 3 years
Iwase, who moved along the street while reading the film that was piled up just
yesterday nejron
rar
me
tl It feels so good
dee dee
me
denham yeah yeah yeah
[music]
But
if you get married and have a child,
one from me  I have some advice,
it's not like we're going to get
weather  When I first entered the
gate, the name was
Saki Ousaki, nasa Kimine,
when adults saw my name, they always laughed a
little nadja.  At
that time, I did
n't know that NASA was an abbreviation for the National Aeronautics and Space Administration,
but
I understood that people were making fun of me.
But even if someone hears my name, I
'll let them say I'm better than 2nd grade NASA
Deep inside, I'm sure there's a soul that goes to extremes when a fire ignites.
But Yuzaki-kun, there's a memo 4 with a deviation value of over 70,
but I think I can do it.
More than a dozen private schools have been recommended
I don't need anti-skid because I don't ski My name is user
Kinasa Nasaku  He's a guy who's fast and
fast.I'm a kid who can study.
Sensei, I don't decide my life after consulting with my parents
.
I'll show it to you
[Music]
I really thought so I've changed everything with my efforts I believed that I could change my destiny
But
this time too, I'm sure I'll be in the middle ranks
Oh
, there was a carpet
I accidentally met fate There
's no
such thing as how old I am Anyway, pretty
Keep it up Wooden sword tan I'm not careful It
was
fatal I never thought I'd die like this Even
though the vinegar hasn't worked yet It doesn't
hurt I don't want to know or see
If I die in a place like this, what was I born for?
It's okay,
people won't die
at this rate, but where is it? Why was
this child different Jazz?  You're the one who was hit hard by the car while protecting yourself, right?
It's like
Princess Kaguya's
consciousness
drifting away.  If it's about that, don't worry about it
[Music]
Come on, come on, the clothes of the big beauty club
More than that, I'll buy the girl from a while ago Ah, millet must be doing Ansei San -- that's
what you're doing,
biker  I know what you want If I run over someone, I'm sure you'll feel the same way,
because if you're a believer, you know that much.
I don't know if I'll be able to find you,
for example, this is
probably the famous
leather
.
I was surprised that I could
move with that
result.As I said earlier, it's not shallow.I really want to thank you.
Isn't everything covered in blood
? You've gone to great lengths to
save me, but you only have one life.
If I don't warm it
up, the warmth of the coat I've put on and the strong sweet scent make
me feel like it's
already snowing And how cute
is this
girl?  I'm really going to die
Uh
oh my job Oh, you've got
both of your legs off ok It's about time that the stir-fry flew right after that, but it's about time you get mad It
's going to be hard to stay conscious soon I
don't want to know  I'm calling an ambulance waiting immobile Well then
, goodbye,
life has become precious
Oh, oh, it looks like the line judge is burning Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
I thought it was Kaguya-hime When the messenger from the moon came, even though he loved Kaguya-hime, the
emperor didn't even fight him
.
Even if I think I'm going to die
I love you
Kita-
kun
I love
you on the road I've been with you for a while and I
don't even know your name
That's why
would you go out with
me  You're going to marry me, I'll go out with you
[music]
Yes,
I'm happy to meet you.
At that time, I was told that if she hadn't intervened, I would probably have died instantly.
Will you go out with me
Looking at the situation, it's safe to say that this was dumped
If you marry me, I'll go out with you If you
think about it now, that answer might have been her own way of refusing
After that, I spent every day studying and rehabilitating. I didn't make it in time for
my exams.
I work full-time at my part-
time
job as a customer service, but that day doesn't come, and I'm worried about my parents, so I rented a small apartment and lived alone in this room
.  I don't think I'm going to get this amount of
money, but I don't really want the money
Right hand again with her
[music]
Hey who?
This is the continuation of the Tale of the Bamboo
Cutter.The Princess Kaguya, who changed her skates, can be happily married
.
Even though I've been with the person I've been continuing with, I'm sorry to bother
you.  Music]
Even so, this girl is really cute.
Just entering the room smells a little nice, and
my name is Suka.
That's why I'm talking about big
breasts,
but this is a marriage registration,
yeah, I've used it.
It hasn't changed,
so it's necessary to report Raccoon 1 for
that.
That kid's merchant,
you need that kind of person to get married By the way, as long as you have a stamp, anyone is
fine, even a stranger passing by.  I need a
copy of my family register and my identification documents, but
it
's
really good I'm writing these documents with this momentum, but
I wonder if something bad will happen No matter how I think about it, I'm buried
It's okay if something bad happens, I'll do something about it
My name is the man who gets faster and faster than
Nanas Yuzaki Yes, I wrote it. Thank
you.
My new name sounds pretty good I
like
it
Dormer  I'm a person, so it
'll be someday, but I'd like to ask for your help
I really have a lot of anxiety
But I'm at the ward office at this
hour.
There are many people like celebrities who want to get married
without being seen by others, right
?  That's right
, compared to that, my name revolves around the
starry sky.  It is
an organization created in 1958 by about 18,000 chosen geniuses
who have turned dreams that no human being could ever achieve into reality through wisdom, effort, courage and perseverance.
Gathering
and going to space is not as easy as it
sounds Literally repeated failures and challenges as many as the number of stars
And
that endless effort eventually succeeded in sending mankind to the moon A
starry sky and no rotation A
wonderful name  I
felt something that had been stuck deep in my heart since I was born was receding I
don't have any real
feelings about marriage, but my desire to marry this girl is
real  It's a
marriage registration. Please wait a moment. Yes, it's
here.
So, let me accept this.Is it
okay if the parents don't have to be together?
Congratulations on
your marriage.  It's easy, isn't it
?  It feels good and this is marriage,
isn't it great?
Where
were you drowning?
A story about a married couple,
yes I finished some errands and expected them to take
it home first.
Hey,
hey hey,
futon Getting married means that we're going to live together in
that house.  I'm married,
but from now on it's going to stop